[Música]
es el momento de cinco minutos con juan
manuel vázquez nuestro invitado de hoy
él es ingeniero agrónomo y director
ejecutivo del instituto latinoamericano
passivhaus quien nos hablará del impacto
de la industria de la construcción en la
crisis climática
-juan manuel gracias por estar con
nosotros y quiero comenzar preguntándole
el crecimiento económico y la
industrialización son muy comúnmente
rivales de la estabilidad del medio
ambiente en qué consiste este impacto
buenos días y gracias a ustedes por
convocar me el crecimiento económico si
es el gran impacto cuando la economía es
tomada en un planeta biológico como una
ecuación lineal y no una ecuación
circular como debería ser ahí es donde
la construcción impacta muy fuertemente
y particularmente con el cemento como
material principal con una enorme
energía embebida en carbono en ese
material
mire la industria aumenta la producción
de gases de efecto invernadero y ese
también es un problema cuál es el
llamado para que el desarrollo sea
sostenible y con esto doble pregunto la
importancia de no solamente la
disminución de materiales sino la
reutilización de los mismos
básicamente el tema pasa por utilizar
materiales de baja energía en bebida en
carbono o sea utilizar justamente
materiales de la fotosíntesis actual así
les llamamos eso es principalmente lo
que deberíamos hacer hoy tenemos gracias
a la evolución en los materiales
materiales de la fotosíntesis actual que
pueden competir en una escala importante
con el cemento o el hormigón que es hoy
el rey de los materiales de la
construcción
las medidas de adaptación para ser más
amigables con el planeta no responden
actualmente a las necesidades para que
sea controlada la crisis climática prima
la economía y nos falta entender que nos
estamos quedando sin planeta en los
niveles de extracción de las materias
primas pues son demasiado altos o para
los recursos que existen
justamente necesitamos utilizar materias
primas renovables en lo que hace a la
construcción y en la evolución de estos
materiales la madera es el más
importante con la madera contra laminada
como principal actor
bueno y ahora quisiera preguntarle que
técnicas modernas de construcción
podrían ayudar a mitigar el impacto que
se está teniendo sobre la crisis
climática
justamente utilizando estos materiales
que a diferencia de emitir carbono los
secuestran lo toman y lo forman parte de
sus fibras podemos construir y generar
una industria regenerativa en lugar de
emitir carbono
secuestramos carbono hacemos que ese
carbono forme parte de nuestros
mampuestos y hacemos que esas nuevas
viviendas o edificios emitan menos al
ser más eficientes en el uso de la
energía
esto acompañado de que existen
dificultades para que estas técnicas se
generen se generalicen en el mundo de la
construcción para que sea también un
negocio rentable y bueno aquí se enmarca
el tema de la sostenibilidad
si totalmente sin duda pero eso es un
tema que el poder lo tenemos nosotros lo
tiene la gente a la hora de decidir qué
comprar y qué materiales usar y ahí es
donde pido a las industrias que
comuniquen de manera ética lo que cada
material provoca o deja de provocar no
entonces es ahí a través de el poder del
que decide el consumo esto de poder
cambiar a este mercado necesitamos
cambiarlo porque si no no vamos a poder
llegar a los objetivos de desarrollo
sostenible que están planteados gracias
a ustedes juan manuel vázquez ingeniero
agrónomo nuestro invitado de hoy en
france 24 ustedes continúen con nosotros
tenemos mucha más programación
[Música]